there's a tweet from Logan Hall Logan
Clark Hall he's the um digital at
thenewfounding.org and used to be the
Daily Caller he said seems like Biden's
speech equating conservatives with
terrorists worked as intended September
24th elderly pro-life volunteer in
Michigan shot after heated conversation
pro-life group says the elderly Michigan
woman was going door to door discussing
a ballot proposal on abortion then we
have Pennsylvania pro-life activists
arrested by FBI charged with assaulting
a clinic escort prosecutors say Mark
Houck twice assaulted a man outside a
Planned Parenthood clinic on the same
day last year it's overtly partisan then
of course we have Kaylor elsing
ellingson's alleged killer not under
house arrest no curfew after posting
very low Bond former assistant U.S
attorney says the very low bond is
woefully inadequate not only that but I
was reading that the guy who killed that
that's the 18 year old kid who was
killed and the guy said he was a
republican extremist I read that in his
bail hearing he was shocked that the
courts were holding it against him like
apparently he he assumed they'd
congratulate him or something or be
alive Kevin killed the kids yes for
having killed an 18 year old like so uh
one of the articles I read said he he
expressed shock at that he would be held
accountable for killing this 18 year old
kid that's one way to try and defend
yourself so
pro-lifer being shot yeah it really does
sound like
it works at face value it does but I
want to see like when they say heated
conversation like was the guy like come
on like how he did what was he screaming
the lady that shot him no no who yelled
I think you're talking about the 18 year
old that got killed 18 years
conversation yes elderly what's this he
did yeah well I mean I've seen some
nasty oh come on dude 84.
stop killing babies and you're like all
right she's gotta go like that's what I
mean you have the right to free speech
but you also there's consequences to get
in people's face so yeah but what's the
story you shouldn't shoot old ladies I
think is a general rule in society right
I gotta I want to see me okay but it was
she was an unarmed old lady knocking on
doors like you don't answer the door
people knock on my door I don't ever
answer my door ever uh I would love to
go deeper into that story to be honest
the the heated conversation
because man the news just does spin
stuff oh boy okay so here's the story
from uh Yahoo results are changing
quickly does an elderly pro-life
volunteer in Michigan was shot in the
shoulder while canvassing a neighborhood
to discuss an abortion about proposal
according to the right to life in
Michigan the victim said she was shot in
the back slash shoulder while leaving a
residence during a heated conversation
and that the man who shot her was not
part of the conversation
the unidentified woman is 83 years old
according to police so the right to life
of Michigan identified her as 84 years
old in a press release the wind was
canvassing a neighborhood in Lake Odessa
to discuss the state's voting proposal 3
which would protect abortion access in
the state the state will vote on The
Proposal November 8th
the victim does not know the Identity or
motive of the shooter a for shooter the
victim is still recovering from her
gunshot wound and wishes to remain
anonymous while the criminal
investigation proceeds now this is just
according to right to life so I think if
she wants to have a bigger political
impact she needs to come forward and
explain what happened and we need to be
able to get to to investigate this well
shot in the back I mean that clearly
shows that she wasn't aggressing or
moving towards somebody since the Bullet
Hole is is there uh so so that that
pretty much says it all like what kind
of coward shoots an old lady in the back
I don't know someone that wasn't even
involved in the conversation exactly
yeah did you see the video there was
another video where a woman is going
door to door and then the lady starts
screaming at her and chases her off the
property I haven't seen that I just
gotta say like you know to Scott Adams
when he tweeted that Republicans would
be hunted everyone kind of rolled their
eyes and they were like whoa a little
over the top there Scott and then we
actually saw people get shot and killed
right beaten up chased and then we were
land with a car and now and now more
recently run down with a car and we're
like yeah actually it may have seemed to
little bombastic but it is starting to
happen now for Scott to come out and be
like neighbors aren't attacking each
other and I'm like yo this old ladies
got shot in the back do you guys think
it kind of is we're canvassing and
having political discussions with people
do you think that hate is ever good
hate knows of course what do you mean I
don't think hate is a good thing I hate
rabid dogs I mean like right but what's
the use of hating them why is that
better than not just like any emotion it
serves yeah but like okay I I think the
idea is like irrational hate is bad
right but hate from a logical place like
they're they're they're they're really
extreme emotion like what's the what's
the use of it to keep you safe so for
example like why do we feel sick looking
at like a a dead animal because we have
a natural response to that
to feel sick and want to be away from it
and vomit why because it's got disease
and and infection and things like that
and so the humans that were not
disgusted by it may have eaten it and
been contaminated and died and those who
were disgusted by it and vomited who so
the vomiting is clear I mean I'm not an
evolutionary biologist but yeah this is
more of a disgust thing than a hate
thing right the point of hate is like
there could be a certain thing being
done by
name name name creature yeah rabbit
dog's a good one attacking a family
member like there might be someone who's
like I just hate these these these Wild
Hogs
I need my NR 15. back in the day you'd
see a wild hog and you'd get angry and
then you'd stop it before it destroyed
your crops or harmed your family you
could just be logical about it too like
I don't think your emotions are better
emotions hate human human emotion you
know comes from this place of what you
know of survival so I want to love
things that help us and protect us and
make us feel good and we hate things
that hurt us and and cause if you have
like a rabid dog that was threatening
your your family and about to kill them
you could logically destroy the rabid
dog without any emotional attached
because you know it's the right thing to
do starting to feel like hate towards it
feels like it's taking over I'll give
you a better example a guy and his
daughter out in the backyard and they're
playing with a frisbee when a rabid dog
runs up and bites her neck ripping
severing her carotid and she bleeds out
in 20 seconds he then says I hate that
dog and he starts a whole Revenge plot
where he goes and buys a bunch of guns
and he's got a board tracking the dog
and then he hunts it down he goes
Revenge when he puts it down that hatred
he felt saved another child from being
killed by that rabid dog that's the
point yeah there's like movies about
like some uh Jason no not Jason Bourne
it was that Keanu Reeves movie where
someone kills his dog and then he goes
on a revenge and it's like glorifying
hate is it a little different was he
feeling hate he was feeling hate towards
the people that killed his dog and that
and that is it's a little more extreme
but it is a good point that those were
really bad people who broke into his
house beat him and killed the dog it's
like now you went extreme with it like
yeah no they killed this dog come on
like I mean like what do you think do
you think it was reasonable
dozens of people over himself do you
think that it's a reasonable to hate
someone who disagrees with you over
political matter like is that something
that is a worthwhile undertaking hate
and that regard what do you mean by
worthwhile undertaking well I think I
think hate is totally fine I think you
just don't want to attack people and you
want to be reasonable like you're
allowed to hate people hate is a hate is
a fine emotion but you should be
rational about it and you shouldn't act
you shouldn't act out upon it so you can
be like yo I just really hate people who
throw litter out of their cars and don't
care and are polluting everything like I
genuinely despise that yeah I hate that
attack the person you hate reaction no
no people who gloat and laugh as they
throw waste do you see people gloating
and laughing I see people actually you
know what I really hate actually I will
use the term is uh parents will show
their kids to throw trash on the street
in Brooklyn and that really makes my
blood boil my point is like there are
things that we universally despise like
a serial killer who gloats about
murdering like I hate that person like I
genuinely despise people who want to
victimize I don't like uh violent like
you see that video of the guy in the
convenience store imagine the store
clerk is on his knees and the guy walks
up behind him and the store looks like
give him whatever he wants and then the
dude just kills him anyway I genuinely
hate that guy yeah what that means is I
think about what he did I think about
what he believes in and who he is and I
hate everything about what brought him
to that point and and that guy right now
hate him
so you gotta be reasonable about it
reasonable about it what we don't want
is irrational hatred where you just hate
someone because of the way they look but
it's rational I don't think it's
rational it literally it's an emotional
discharge okay so this guy literally
shot and killed a dude on his knees who
was uh cooperating so if you were like a
military commander you'd be like we need
to execute the the threat but you're not
like
that you can't control don't change the
subjects well if you're if you're gonna
walk a guy walked into you're
exclusively handling it a guy walked
into a store and aggressed upon another
person who complied and killed him for
no reason yes I hate that person but
like and the response should be we need
to stop them with that hatred and that
anger that I feel it is what is the
appropriate way to stop a person like
this and how do we prevent it from
happening in the future that hatred is
what leads us to stopping the thing from
happening you can do it without hate too
vengeance is very dangerous because when
someone's becomes emotional we're
talking about emotionally charged
responses it's not the same thing we're
not talking about the same thing hateful
response is a form of engine is a form
of Revenge Revenge on the guy I want him
to be stopped yeah yeah this might be a
definitional issue maybe yeah semantics
I think hate I think that's fine it's an
emotion it's fine you're allowed to feel
emotions emotions serve a purpose and
they're part of The Human Experience
yeah but emotional leaders are dangerous
like haters I hate wasps like I I
actually like those people from New
England
singing venomous incense
they don't make honey like what are they
even doing I don't know what wasps are
okay
with me yesterday
some wasps kill but other bugs I'm fine
with that like stink bugs the reason we
have stink bug problem now in the east
coast is because they're native to China
and there's a wasp in China that hunts
them in the air and so he kills them in
the air we don't need to bring those
we don't need those okay
the stink bugs stink bugs are at least
cute like they're doofy and they like
walk around and they clap for you you
ever see the stink bugs clap stink bugs
no but I saw spider cricket yesterday
and that freaked we got a bunch of those
what the oh did not like it yeah they're
all Cricket there's like 7 000 in the
skate parks I was reaching into a bucket
to get some goat food and there was that
spider cricket so so listen why do I
hate wasps because they don't do
anything good for me they build nests
they attack people they swarm and when
they sting you you go to the hospital
yeah it's bad so like I have a very
negative emotional reaction to them and
when I see them I'm like I must remove
that wasp's nest they can build anywhere
off my front porch but now they're
building on my front porch so we have to
get wasp spray it's a whole thing yeah
but that's not a hate that's not real
hate there was a mountain the other day
I kind of hated it and but it was also
sort of cute but I still hated it people
have pets as Mouse yeah but I didn't I
don't need a I don't need a feral Mouse
as a pet living in my kitchen
it was unpleasant I guess it maybe we're
just talking about different definitions
of the word hate because like I think
you and I are talking similar
infestation which is why I said hate is
fine but irrational hate is yeah well so
and acting acting out in a negative way
because of hatred is also look you feel
you have these humans feel emotions
you're allowed to feel them they're all
good so you have the Michigan guy is
doing irrational hate just like the
North Dakota guy irrational hate no no
no no no no you don't think these guys
are actions are the problem not the
emotion you can feel however you do you
think this guy had irrational hate this
uh Michigan old lady shooter yes
irrational but the problem isn't just
that he's a rational and hatred the
problem is that he shot someone like if
you're outside and you're going oh I'm
just so full of hate I'd be like well
you know enjoy it yeah I mean some
people have a good time sure that's
that's it maybe that's their Baseline
look it's part of the human experience
to feel ways about things like if we
were just like we shouldn't feel hate is
bad let's just be logical beings it's
like okay come on you know like we
experience life in a variety of ways and
some people are more hateful than others
but I think hate love fear all these
things we chase fear is fear bad people
jump off buildings on purpose because
you get that Adrenaline Rush that fear
and then you survive it yeah but it's
also jumping off a building who does
that are you joking surviving jumping
off buildings uh-huh oh like if you
repel off buildings like base jumping oh
yeah I hate that bungee jumping but
anyway I think it's also important to
note here that that people can't control
their emotions more and more a lot of
people's nervous systems are fried
doctors are being told by medical boards
to ask everyone if they have anxiety I
think there also is a not only a mental
health crisis but a physical health
crisis that is leading to a lot of the
insanity that we're dealing with the
consequences of in the streets in New
York City in San Francisco that that
truly is a way bigger problem very much
complex and I think it all boils down to
a lot of food being poisoned a lot of
individuals not having a good mental
health and not controlling their
emotions and then lashing out and acting
crazy which we're seeing more and more
of on on big Tech social media and
whether we're seeing it deliberately
because social media wants to show it to
us specifically or whether it's really
happening I I think it still deserves to
be talked about from a fair perspective
because there are a lot of people
struggling out there that do need help I
had um we have I want to jump to this
next story you know well yeah about just
about like on Friday we had a show with
Nick Paul Machado was on the show and it
was I had a hard time with it I felt
like I was going to puke for a lot of it
because you and him were going deep and
you guys were really going to HR about
Civil War and why not and why is why not
why maybe why no and so I was like just
in a nasty mood this weekend like that
that energy I carried and I was stressed
out like what are we doing are we
propagating this thing without realizing
it and then I heard about the storm
called Ian coming and part of me was
like fine let the storm let the storm
land and I'm like what am I doing what
have I become am I like becoming the
evil that I that I hate and so I had to
change my emotions I I disengaged from
the machine meaning my computer I
cleared my mind and just thought about
dissipating the clouds and had to like
re-navigate my own emotions which I do
believe is possible which is why I think
if you feel hate you could change it
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there